ask you a question honestly when did you
start believing what you're saying now
when I started listening to people
no no no honestly when when like when
specifically did you start I would say I
to be I've always grown up with that
belief of let people be whatever they
want to believe and let me explain okay
I'm a minority right being black in the
UK especially I know how hard it is when
the majority think that you are in the
wrong and maybe that is that compassion
that I have for them because we are the
majority we have the privilege because
we were born as our gender so we have
the privilege to say no that's how you
everyone was born as their gender no no
the gender that we identify as